et pendant ce temps dominique de
villepin lui a passé la journée à la
réunion le premier ministre est venu
vérifier la mise en oeuvre des mesures
contre le chikungunya annoncé lors de
son précédent voyage une épidémie qui
n'est toujours pas terminée l'accueil a
été chaleureux reportage jean baptiste
près dali francis forget ces temps ci à
la réunion le chikungunya se porte sur
ces t-shirts qu'on vend dans les
boutiques et même face au premier
ministre un comédien peut en faire un
sketch pour dominique de villepin c'est
un retour fin février ils étaient sur
place
quarante cinq mille personnes étaient
alors touché dans l'île chaque semaine
1500 cas nouveau seulement ont été
signalés la semaine dernière un reflux
concept et à saint paul un des foyers de
l'épidémie on peut pas dire aujourd'hui
que la situation elle est enrayée
totalement le chikungunya peut reprendre
cela dépendra effectivement de la
vigilance déjà des réunionnais et des
moyens pour mettre en oeuvre 20 millions
d'euros débloqués pour un plan sanitaire
l'armée en renfort pour des moustiques
et un traitement expérimenté de cette
mobilisation dominique de villepin tire
une leçon très politique
en venant ici comme chef du gouvernement
je veux vous le dire je puise dans votre
exemple je sais que la tâche a été rude
tout cela c'est ce qui nous fait marcher
et je dis bien marcher ensemble
c'est cela la république après la crise
la danse dominique de villepin savoure
ces deux jours loin de paris ce voyage à
la réunion et la lutte contre le
chikungunya
c'est pour lui comme un exemple
l'exemple d' engagements pris et tenue
d'une action dans la durée et de
quelques résultats obtenus de l'action
et des résultats c'est justement ce qu'a
demandé jacques chirac au gouvernement